bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france24 notre invité aujourd'hui et
christophe lutundula il est vice premier
ministre et ministre des affaires
étrangères de la république démocratique
du congo il est avec nous depuis
kinshasa merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
oui merci beaucoup de m'avoir invité
alors ce lundi l'armée congolaise a
annoncé que deux soldats ont été tués et
cinq blessés dans une attaque attribuée
aux groupes rebelles du m23 dans l'est
de la rdc ceci après que ce week-end le
président tshisekedi a affirmé je le
cite n'avoir aucun doute sur le soutien
du rwanda au m23 veut ni je le cite
agressé la rdc alors une question toute
simple mais grave est-ce qu'on se dirige
vers une guerre entre le rwanda et la
rdc
permettez-moi d'abord de saluer la
mémoire des sites et vaillants soldats
soldats congolais qui prouvent par leur
engagement la détermination de notre
pays de défendre son intégrité
territoriale et sa souveraineté
non la guerre n'avons pas l'ambition les
tensions jamais le congo n'a rêvé un
jour la porte saint geours de livrer
guerre à qui que ce soit parmi nos
voisins
je pense que la gravité de la situation
qui vient une fois de plus de se
confirmer
et ce site une solution urgente
tous les efforts qui ont été déployés au
niveau des milieux africaine au niveau
des nations unies au niveau de nos
partenaires bilatéraux doivent se
conjuguer davantage pour mettre fin à
cette crise qu'elle 1,23 avec ses
parrains du rwanda
en déclencher mais l'armée par exemple à
propos de cet incident dit que
l'utilisation de canons de longue portée
prouve le soutien actif du rwanda au m23
ceux-ci seul ce lundi après justement
les tentatives de médiation à ce que ce
n'est pas d'une certaine façon une fin
de non recevoir de la part de kigali à
toutes ses tentatives
bon d'abord une petite précision il n'y
a pas que l'utilisation des armes
lourdes il ya le fait qu' à deux milité
rouennais qui ont été capturés par le
derby congolaise et le rwanda n'a pas
contesté et il ya aussi le fait que moi
même j'ai été informé officiellement par
me coller droit dès qu'ils allaient
faire ce qu'ils font même la fin de non
recevoir
bon je ne sais pas si c'est cela mais ce
qui est vrai c'est que cela prouve à
suffisance que le rwanda indéterminée a
violé toutes les règles de droit
international et tout ce que nous avons
convenu dans le cadre bilatéral de
rwandais tenterait plutôt de défier les
médiateurs les présidents de rinceaux de
l'argot la présidence de la ceni est
réel nous espérons que lui la citation
et qu'il en tirera toutes les
conséquences pour notre part ça ne va
pas
entamer notre détermination notre
fermeté comme je vous ai dit à défendre
l'intégrité territoriale et
l'indépendance de notre pays oui
monsieur le ministre si vous dites que
le rwanda soutient un groupe qui vous
agressent pour reprendre les mots de
votre président ça appelle des mesures
de rétorsion or il n'y en a pas est ce
que vous envisagez un gel une suspension
des relations diplomatiques avec le
rwanda pour exprimer votre
mécontentement
nous avons déjà pris certaines mesures
à l'issue de la réunion du conseil
supérieur de la défense pour le moment
nous n'excluons aucune option mais nous
faisons totalement confiance aux
médiateurs le président lorrain sow est
né et rien qui puisse compliquer sa
tâche alors justement le président
lorenzo a utilisé cette médiation pour
négocier la libération de ces deux
soldats rwandais dont vous avez parlé à
l'heure mon parlent ils n'ont toujours
pas été libérés est-ce que vous allez
les libérer ou est ce que vous attendez
justement peut-être des garanties du
rwanda bon ce qui est vrai c'est que la
parole a été donnée je venais de vous
dire que nous n'avons pas les tensions
de compliquer la tâche au président de
rinceaux et à la cia ciel sans compter
l'union africaine mais
il faut dire que
nous nous suivons l'agenda du médiateur
et nous voulons aussi qu'
il y ait des gestes de bottes de bord
froid des signaux
convaincant que nous allons nous sommes
engagés dans un processus de règlement
durable il y a notamment le fait que les
m23 avec le soutien des douanes a
continué à occuper deux localités
congolaises vous n'êtes pas dire à
chasser les compatriotes de leur
domicile cela est inadmissible le fait
qu'il y à des attaques on venait d'en
parler donc je pense que tout doit aller
ensemble nous avons fait un geste de
paix un geste de bonne volonté nous
espérons que le médiateur en tient
compte et qui prend son mieux pour que
nous puissions avancer à avec des
garanties mais donc vous n'allez pas les
libérer pour le moment
nous allons les libérer ça dépend de
l'agenda du médiateur d'accord est ce
que ce n'est pas quand même un aveu
d'échec des tentatives de dialogue avec
les groupes armés il ya une réunion à
nairobi il y a quelques semaines est ce
que ce qui se passe avec le m23 ne signe
pas la fin de ses espoirs de paix
négociée dans l'est de votre pays non
absolument pas parce que je je je
rappelle que nous avons déjà eu des
consultations avec cinq en six groupes
armés avec 40
chefs de communautés locales et bientôt
nous allons élargir les consultations à
la société civile de la nuit incluant
bien sûr les femmes et nous en sommes en
train de préparer le deuxième round de
nairobi est en train de préparer aussi
le sommet de tous les chefs d'état de la
communauté de l'afrique de l'est
s'étaient lancés maintenu donc l'un 23
nous avons dit nous ne reviendrons pas
sur notre décision tant qu'elle est là
lui d'un vin toi tu es là nul 2-2 d'une
organisation terroriste nous n'avons pas
à prendre langue avec une organisation
terroriste cela est dit et doit
continuer à être maintenues elles ont
créé pas parce que le v3 n'est pas là
que les discussions vont s'arrêter non
pas du tout est-ce que vous échangez
avec votre homologue rwandais est ce que
le président tshisekedi et le président
kagame échanges en ce moment où est ce
que le dialogue est gelé entre vous
cindy alors le dialogue ne peut passer
que par un médiateur de l'or qui est
médiateur nous n'allons pas donner
l'impression que le nord nous n'allons
pas donner l'impression qu'il n'ya rien
que tout est réglé non pas du tout et
nous ne pouvons pas accepter que ceux ci
font de vous le dire mais je marque
pullman que nous n'allons pas nous
pas d'idée ou
passer à côté de la plaque lorsqu'il
s'agit de la souveraineté de l'intégrité
territoriale de notre pays et du
bien-être de nos populations ça c'est
très clair nous sommes faire alors ce
mardi il y à la première visite
officielle dans votre pays du roi des
belges philippe une visite de six jours
que représente cette visite du roi de
l'ex pays colonisateur pour vous et
d'abord c'est le retour à la normalité
diplomatique vous savez qu avant
l'arrivée des faits les centres anti
security nommé au pouvoir nous étions en
41 diplomatique avec la belgique ont été
à la limite en tout cas
de la rupture nous nous étions au bord
de la rupture et depuis que le président
est là il a relancé l'ouverture des
plots matic donc l'arrivée du roi
consolide cette normalité diplomatique
ensuite cela la confirmation un de ceux
que nous sommes
dans la normalisation mieux la relance
de la coopération avec la belgique qui
était au bord de la rupture comme je
viens de vous le dire et troisièmement
c'est une visite qui a son importance
dans les ca d'entretenir la mémoire de
l'histoire et surtout de confirmer
l'engagement du président du cg dits
durs du gouvernement belge de dette de
de laver cette histoire d'ailleurs on va
bientôt vous le savez rapatrier la
relique despatis le mauvais nous allons
faire nationale donc nous sommes à une
période où on doit la vie l'histoire de
sa saleté et surtout l'engagement de
faire mieux pour les générations futures
alors à propos de laver cette histoire
il ya deux ans le roi avait adressé une
lettre au président tshisekedi dans
laquelle il exprimait je le cite les
plus profonds regrets pour les blessures
entre guillemets de la colonisation
est-ce que désormais vous attendez
quelque chose de plus des excuses
formelles de la belgique pour la période
coloniale
sinon le roi veut
nous présenter des excuses ne l'ont pas
le refuser mais je crois connaître dans
une lancée qui n'est pas moins
significatives dans les sens ce que je
vaux et 10 dont je vous ai parlé les
sens de l'art et l'histoire est donc
dans l'essence de tourner la page de
demander pardon et d'aller de l'avant
donc moi je pense que ce n'est pas une
question préjudicielle
merci beaucoup christophe lutundula
d'avoir répondu aux questions de france
24 depuis kinshasa merci à vous d'avoir
regardé cet entretien sur nos antennes
restez-y pour plus d'informations
[Musique]